la nuit a été particulièrement bruyante
particulièrement ici dans le quartier de
podil c'est dans ce quartier que une
personne a été tuée quatre districts
différents de Kev aurait été frappé
pendant la nuit selon les autorités de
la ville comme vous l'avez dit l'Armée
de l'Air dit tout de même avoir abattu
tous les drones et de missiles de
croisière donc il faut croire que c'est
à cause des fragments qui sont tombés et
que les dégâts auraient été bien plus
importants si les drones ou les missiles
n'avaient pas été interceptés il reste
une missile de type Iskender qui aurait
été tiré depuis le nord de la Crimée
selon les autorités
ukrainiennes qui n'a pas été abattu mais
ils n'ont pas publié d'informations sur
la cible qui aurait été atteint par ce
missile là